for whatever reason it didn't work out i
didn't like it i didn't like you
when i first met you i have to say
something you're telling me that you
didn't like me yeah yeah at first wait a
minute
what i know i i want to i just cause i
in my head you guys rewind and go back
to the
steering no i no i know just listen
to me right i didn't know you
right i i'd see you around
and i didn't know like and so my my
opinion you were was pretty indifferent
now it wasn't like
i didn't like him right i just saw him
on stage i go oh my god he's a beast
right but i just this is years ago by
the way right
and i remember one time i just i don't
know why it popped in my head
i remember one time i was at the laugh
factory and
you walked in with your son your son was
young yeah
on your shoulders right right and that
was an asian night i think too
yeah it was i was like what the is
this guy doing an asian night yeah it
was so highly offended yeah asian people
no they loved totally kidding yeah and
so when i saw you with your son i went
oh like literally it no shut up
for a second all right everyone it made
me i never wanted a kid
until i saw that donald trump
with this kid yeah because i go because
i always think of donnell
in my mind kind of like me you know he's
got a he is
he's looking he looks like a black golem
look at his body
right skinny arms real
weird yeah we're shaking like yeah we're
shaped similar
right he's not buff yeah all right
and so and also comedy wise he's just so
funny the funniest is that michael
jackson cocaine
is so fun but anyway um and when
he started
when and he just just there to give his
son you know i mean
a tour of the club and how close he is
and what a good dad he is
i wanted him to i wanted my son to see
because he knows i'm a comedian
right but i wanted him to be around
the comedy vibe you know what i'm saying
yeah can i even talk to you about it i
think on the show about like what
fatherhood means to me
yeah yeah i'm saying i don't know if you
took yourself out of the game or even
considered whatever
but it's an amazing feeling and then but
it's so weird because i had my son
later in life we talked about this too
where i had got to the point where i'm
like you're not going to have no kids
right i told myself and you have to be
[Music]
mentally prepared for that because it
could you up you know i'm saying i
said i got nieces i got nephews
i got a career whatever and i and i
wasn't gonna go crazy about it but then
when it happened
it was super exciting and then when i
talked to certain people man i just
kind of looked in their face and
kind of can tell sort of
what they need yeah let me ask you
something
when you look at your kid because i see
a bond and a closeness and he loves you
so much
listen to this okay
[Music]
this song he wrote for me the other day
listen
i like to be with you
and i have to play with you
all day long
with you because
this is my greatest daddy
for my life life life
life life life life
then i like
playing with him
before he leaves
and then i give him a hug
and then we say
goodbye but he'll always come back
tomorrow
[Music]
i'm crying right now no listen
listen that's the first one he wrote
to me what is it
i'll climb every time
[Music]
and i also care about you
and i lash you awake
[Music]
me
i'm not crying you're crying i know but
i'm telling you bro
that's my you man and i respect
listen oh
what you said about you know you had
reservations about me or whatever
if uh i could have it's two
things i would want my peers to respect
me for
okay one of them
is being a dope-ass comedian
and one of the best to do it you know i
don't care about
building relationships outside of the
stage like the respected i always felt
like
me personally then you you know i once
you respect what i do as a crafter that
and the second thing is me as a father
you know what i'm saying
and we talked about in the other show
and like i didn't have the connection
like that with my dad he was around he's
in and out in prison whatever
so when i when i when i when i'm when
i'm with my son
i always want to create
the memories that i didn't create with
my father
you know what i'm saying i never went
fishing my father so it's my i gotta
take my
son fishing i never i noticed sound
crazy when we was doing summer camp this
is what made summer camp so dope
chappelle show summer camp
we gave people that was desperate for
entertainment people that were depressed
standing in the house didn't know what
to do we gave them the opportunity to go
out and feel
some type of being normal
you know what i'm saying and but with
that we had activities i've created this
person called the river ninja yeah
you're told me the river ninja
and he was birthed because i was sick of
hollywood
right i'm like hollywood i'm having
problems in my relationship
i need to get the right here i'm
going to kill myself i'm going to kill
somebody else
i went to yellow spring and found
nature i went on one
kayaking trip
and i was like this i'm the river
this is this happened
yeah there's a rip in the gap look at
how you know how many rivers you're
gonna have to get this fuzzy part right
here
yeah yeah i said to myself i embodied
this person
and i said to myself i was like
hollywood i was like
i'm the river i see it from i said
i said from the streets to the creeks
yeah i said from the hoods to the woods
i see it from horse to oars yeah
from adidas to tivos i'm the river
you really wear tivas yes yeah
i love white now listen yeah
like you know what i made fun of them
they're the most comfortable goddamn
shoes
ever and not only that you could do
anything with them
like you could be walking the trail
which i never did
you could be walking the trail yeah you
see a a creek in a swimming hole
guess what
you don't have to change your shoes
[Laughter]
the first black people i took out on the
river and kayaking they put three pairs
of sneakers hey guys we're going to take
a really quick break to share one of our
true sponsors ship station
you guys ship station is a service that
we use here at target valley
the holla